did you really think matt hancock was
useless sir
why didn't you suck him you wouldn't
expect the prime minister to call matt
hancock
useless in public
but today even the health secretary
himself doesn't sound too sure
that's after this man published partial
whatsapp exchanges between him
and the prime minister at the height of
the pandemic about matt hancock
it came in a 7500 word blog
renewing his assault on matt hancock and
boris johnson's administration
in the early hours of the 27th of march
2020 dominic cummings shared a whatsapp
exchange with the prime minister
where he warned the uk is lagging behind
testing regimes in other countries and
criticizes hancock
for being skeptical that we too could
increase capacity fast
the prime minister replied six minutes
later calling the situation totally
expletive hopeless dominic cummings also
shares a message from later that morning
where he is telling the prime minister
they referring to officials totally
effed up
ventilators to which it appears the
prime minister blamed health secretary
matt hancock responding
it's hancock he has been hopeless the
following month we see a message from
the prime minister telling dominic
cummings
on ppe that personal protective
equipment it's a disaster
and that the solution could be replacing
hancock's health secretary with michael
gove
but the former adviser replied saying
that with other parts of government in
chaos
this would make the situation worse not
better
to which the prime minister replied with
yet further
colourful language while clearly only
part of the story
number 10 has not denied that these
messages are authentic
it's an absolute shambles and it shows
that utter failure
at the heart of government this
government has failed yet again and
those messages show really the
crassness and the unprofessionalism
that's at the heart of our government
currently
mps wanted evidence from dominic
cummings to back up his allegations
but what they got from the former
adviser who is pursuing an agenda
against his former colleagues
was brief weaponized messages taken
from over a year ago at the height of
the pandemic the most stressful period
in government
in living memory nevertheless
what it shows is a prime minister who
was it seems unhappy
with his health secretary and who did
have concerns about his government's
handling of the pandemic which is
different
to what he says publicly there's
certainly plenty
unwilling to give cummings the benefit
of the doubt he was an advisor
and if his advice wasn't taken he wasn't
a very good one uh if his advice was
taken
it's the ministers who are responsible
for it and not him
if things went wrong ministers take the
can for it i know matt hancock well
and i know the job of being health
secretary even better
and i know matt hancock will not have
gone into meetings
in number 10 with the prime minister or
anyone else
and told them lies the ice to the right
461
the nose to the left 60. the timing of
the criticism did not help today
as mps were being asked to vote on a
four-week extension to covet regulations
triggering a large number of tory
abstentions amid many voicing concerns
if you create hope and then shift the
goal posts again
people continue to deepen their despair
i cannot find a way
to explain to my constituents why
the things they are looking forward to
getting back to doing
can't have to wait it is time to trust
people
more it is time to control people
less another result from dominic
cummings another rebellion in the
commons everyone tetchy in the muggy
summer heat
sam coates sky news